so tell me how you got put on
so i got put on when i was 12 years old
i got put on by six dudes they all was
grown
my bro he took me up there he was
[ __ ] with my sister but he was
already game-making so i used to go
around to the house and said he'll
always be like make sure you get
pronounced you can put on so one day i'm
like [ __ ] it my sister's asleep i'm on
sleeve we sneak out we go i got put on
that night you know my sick grown ass
man they whipped my eyes
it was brutal what did they do they were
whipping my they stumped me out they
just was just whooping my ass man
they're trying to hit me i fell down
it was bad but after after that ass
whooping it was love
i felt love
which you didn't feel in your family
kind i felt more loved i felt more love
in her yes i did i felt like it was more
support how old were you and this
happened i was 12 years old 12. yes sir
that changed the direction of your life
totally made your way right corrupted
so how much prison time have you done
see i did five
what kind of stuff are you doing after
12 years old uh 12 um i don't know bad
ass kid pulling firecrackers and um the
girls backpacks and [ __ ] and you know
just bad kid corrupted just corrupted
man
i don't know i moved to um south central
all the black people i don't know
i got caught up
i did you're proud to be a [ __ ] i am
i'm really young how old are you now i'm
25. 25.
and it says it's crips bloods there's
hoovers hoovers are called hoovers are
criminals they're called you got
gangsters
cases moving they say moving
they go about third you for me i don't
do none of them
i don't do none of them
see i'm from neighborhood
family we khaki blue
we don't do the other side something
that we just don't do and bloods call
each other down moves that moves
and crips call each other what crips
this crisp by saying crabs
yup
and what's it like what's gang life in
prison like to be honest um it's like
more militant it's more serious it's way
more serious than the streets i feel
like in prison it's way tougher in the
streets it's way tougher than the
streets because
people is in there and it's like more
they all they do they're gonna just do
so all they do is just gang bang it's
who who's gonna come in and i've seen
some [ __ ] happen on them yards man
i see some [ __ ] happens man i was part
of some of that [ __ ] man
some of that violence i didn't want to
but you don't got no choice when you get
up there
you really got no choice it's out of you
you're gonna do it or they're gonna get
two
you can't hide
if you roll it up at the end of your
career
you'll be running
so look at
don't fold
if you want to join that lifestyle don't
fall be ready for what you're about to
get into straight up
[ __ ] ain't no game what's the quality
you need most to do this um you need on
street street street smart you need to
be wise
just have a good head on your shoulder
need courage courage hard it don't be
scary it's okay to be scared but just
don't be no [ __ ]
straight up like just go in there like
you want a gay man
there's nothing good though nothing good
in it
what do they say death or uh the other
prisoners that the prison that's really
what's going to happen
as you stand here and what do you think
makes that attractive to a young man
um to be honest i think it's the um
the boldness the like the braveness the
toughness
um probably how the other females
you know the female crowd they kind of
go towards the game members so the young
dude he'll probably see that and be like
he might be a follower become a follower
and want to be like them that's what
that's what i that's what i was i was a
follower kind of sort of
you're better off being a leader
yes
it's way more better it's a better view
i'll top that
tell me about karma karma oh that's a
[ __ ]
it's gotta be with this life right yeah
she gonna come back trust and believe
one way or other like my mama said what
goes around comes around trust me it
might not come back it might happen
tomorrow the next day or [ __ ] 10 years
from now but trust me they gonna get
their revenge somehow
yup
it's real
that's gotta make it rough to go through
your life rough but sometimes when
you're doing [ __ ] and you're taking [ __ ]
or whatever you're doing if you're doing
bad just don't give a [ __ ] you can't
give a [ __ ] once you give a [ __ ] you're
gonna [ __ ] up
if you're gonna do that do that don't
try to go in there and then if you're
gonna be a tough guy don't try to go in
there and be tough and then now
something you want to be all nice and
[ __ ] like
stay committed tell me about your uh
your family my family they're doing good
my mom you know she at home my sister
and [ __ ] you have your dad i never met
him never met my dad but uh yeah my mom
thought that i was gang banging she
slapped me in juvenile homes she came to
see me
i did 18 months there i got censored
with three months there but i did 18
months though
by getting refiled every time you fight
you get an extra three months
so i started with three i ended up with
18 months
yeah that was crazy so yeah it was tough
overall they're doing all right i'm home
i'm home
we all free man
so it's good
free tell me about the tattoos on your
face tattoos on my face oh my that's my
hood turn this way
and then turn the other way
yeah master hood man i got the hood
tasks on me
for me i'm committed man i made it i
made a decision so i'm gonna rock with
it that's gonna make it hard for you to
get a job at chipotle may not accept all
my consequences
as long as you accept your consequences
take it like a man you'll be all right
so would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
uh where i want to be when i get into
that mode
i'm a good guy though i'm funny and sad
but like
it all depends who i'm around what about
how the environment is what's the for me
how it is what's the temperature out
there like
i'm just going to give a [ __ ]
what they whatever they want my master
energy your environment's everything
again everything yep
and family and family that's your
environment god first then family
you have to go a long way keep them
you have kids i have one
who is with a daughter a daughter who's
she with about her mother her name pinky
my daughter named kimayo you see her you
see no i do not
because i'm out here for me and you
already know my sister
yeah hi as a [ __ ] my children do
see me right now i'm not you for me nah
i've rather heard not see me
i really don't i'm still young you feel
me
i care but it's like i care but then
it's like
i'm still young and i'm thugging so it's
like
i care but i'm thugging though you feel
that's like being in the hood on the
phone talking to your [ __ ] you slipping
don't get your head blown off
or trying to pop out a bit going across
the street in your hood so you're
turning between being a good guy and a
bad guy good guy and a bad guy yo
i think i think i'm a good guy but make
bad decisions i think so
i finally realized that
where do you see your life going from
here
man a billionaire
billionaire probably standard trump
towers
how's that gonna happen oh no no i'm
gonna do it but i'm gonna do it though
are drugs part of the picture for you
drugs um it's not gonna it's not a it's
not gonna be a um
all thing of my life it's gonna stop but
for right now i'm enjoying it
what is that first on that um yes sir
that's a popular drug now isn't it very
popular very popular i'm going to rush
to look at people weird who said they
did that [ __ ] once they told me they did
it i swear to god i cut them off
i didn't want them no part of my life
like you do drugs like i'm straight
it's weird though everybody's doing it
now
especially black people
and what does chris smith do for you
um it gives me a strife
punched me up had me ready for whatever
like if i get hit by a truck i feel like
i'll survive it if i get shot somebody
shoot me i feel like i survive because i
don't know it's just
it's bad but it helps you out a lot too
though
it
sharpens you
or it can make you paranoid depends on
my game mine never matters so it's
whatever you you want to expect like if
you're weak minded you don't get [ __ ]
straight up
how many days you go without sleep on
that [ __ ] like a month
incredible hulk [ __ ]
and then when you do sleep you sleep for
how long i'll probably sleep for like
two days
get right back to it man hitler almost
took over the world with this [ __ ]
hillary discovered it's it blame it on
hillary
yup
hair was a bad guy
do you believe in god
yeah i do
and once i did it but then
later on down the line i finally found i
finally realized it was a guy like i
felt them
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
so always to always
go to a first mind
and make the right decision and don't
follow and don't let nobody um
push you over and don't be no yes man
don't always just don't you know yes man
to every anything
just don't just know
as a man as a woman that you're an adult
and you do have the right to make your
own decision
so don't let what i learned is that you
know
make your own decision i don't know just
be yourself
don't try to be nobody else
i learn i can't find a word i can't i
think i'm trying to think of the word
but i can't really
i can't figure it out man
i'm like i can't figure it out but yeah
i think that's about it
think for yourself
think for yourself
you've been in love before
once i don't like it
i don't like it um i felt it it was this
one girl her name was trinisha um but
she was cool but she was like um kind of
like a bugaboo
but she was sexy though but like just a
bugaboo want to be my face all day i
want to be a player
i can't see someone with my face i'm
pushing her off
and making those too short i end up
breaking up with the [ __ ]
but once i broke up with her that's what
i found out i loved her it was weird
how much i really like need one needed
her like my mom outside you for me i was
doing good like when she was around i
was doing good once he left i just
started going downhill going back to
jail
all the shits
yup
so y'all felt it i don't like it i still
love that [ __ ]
and she moved on already got kids and
all that
i see her like [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] with
her like
but i [ __ ] that up man
[ __ ] it up sometimes you lose
snooze you lose
is that one of the mistakes you've
learned from is that one of the mistakes
you've learned from in your life yes
to keep something
something something special hold on to
it
you consider yourself lucky
yes
yes i do you're live yes sir
yes you got friends that are dead right
a lot
a whole lot and i'll be thinking like
that i could have been there with them
but yeah i'd be somewhere else i've seen
so many guys like yourself that are much
older they've survived and all their
friends have been murdered or whatever
and it's almost like they had a
something protecting them from you gotta
you gotta you gotta be thirsty out there
you gotta see i'm a thirsty [ __ ] you
gotta be thirsty
you just gotta be on everything you can
make you got to watch every car that
pass you ought to be on everything
win everything especially in south
central you must be on everything don't
just be walking thinking it's good
be on everything that you got to be on
everything
and bang on everything don't try to
think where [ __ ] bang on that [ __ ]
and if you got him you know what to do
after that
what emotion do you deal with most
uh get angry depressed depressed more
stress
trying to just try to make everything
happen what are you worried about
my mom my sister
yup
if they eating good you know
money in a pocket you know enjoy life
that's what i
i don't know i haven't been there so
i just uh
pretty they doing good though
tell me how shane plays a part in your
life
say that one more time how shame plays a
part in your life same a lot like guilt
or shame same yeah a lot
um what was my family about it i feel
like i um kind of like turn my back on
them
even though i'm grown
and i can do what i please
but i still feel like my mom leave me
and i kind of like just like brushed it
off like even though she'd been there
for me the autumn times going to
juvenile hall all the schools i didn't
got kicked out of find out i'm a crib
you know tattoos on my face
anybody else probably would have left
their kids already like you know what
you're on your own but yeah she still
rock with me come visit me put money on
my books
you feel me still be like if i go right
now she's gonna welcome you
good woman
yo good woman very good woman
you lucky to have that yes yes sir
what advice would you give to a young
man who's considering
joining a gang
man look don't be stupid man gangbang is
not cool man you see you see the funnest
of it they see the funnest of the
popularity of it is all popularity
publicity they look at that and they see
that like man if i do this i'm gonna be
popping okay right now with the state
that they're in right now they're like a
nerd geek not getting no ladies
so
gangbanging is not cool man trust me
it's a bad time too when it's time to go
slide and do all that
trust me you don't want to go through
that trust me don't do it man just get a
job go to college get them hotties
and try to get um try to work at
chick-fil-a your square be a square
straight up square is the best thing man
go anywhere i can't go anywhere
and no tattoos on the face
do you regret the game yeah i don't
don't say it like that i don't know do
you regret the tattoos on your face i
like it but i don't because it's just
it's not good it got it's good but then
it got it's bad too so just to cancel
all that to prevent all that just don't
get them
someone get your interview on your job
you for sure get it it won't be no
exceptions
all right face great talking to you yeah
i wish you the best of luck now all
right thanks